[Music]
on this Friday night Co bid 19 the risk
of it spread to the highest level this
is the reality check what all countries
including Canada are being warned to
prepare for wake up get ready this virus
may be on its way as fears drive down
global stock markets even further Plus
while we're not getting a true picture
of how many people are infected trying
to end the impasse fresh talks between
with so itand hereditary chiefs and
government ministers a global news
exclusive how Canadian terrorism
offenders are leaving prison still
radicalized and from working the
checkout to winning a jackpot
the young supermarket employee bagging
on windfall
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
countries and companies around the world
are focused on Co vid 19 tonight as new
cases emerge more than 50 countries have
confirmed cases of the new corona virus
now and the World Health Organization
has raised its alert to the highest
level and around there are reports from
hospitals of a big spike in deaths more
than 200 that is six times higher than
the official death toll from the Iranian
Health Ministry this all beyond what it
was high Inquisition many believe it's
downplaying what's really going on mass
disinfection is underway at mosques and
on public transit schools are closed for
three days and many flights to and from
Iran have been canceled the World Health
Organization now admits we are on the
precipice of a pandemic this is a
reality check for every government on
the planet wake up get ready this virus
may be on its way and you need to be
ready you have a duty to your citizens
you have a duty to the world to be ready
we'll get to what Canadian public health
officials are doing to ramp up the
response here in just a moment but we
begin with the stock market it went into
a tailspin again today across Asia
Europe and here in North America the TSX
closed down 454 points and Wall Street
suffered its worst week since the
financial crisis of 2008 the Dow Jones
tanked today closing a staggering week
with a loss of about 3500 points in just
five days it's all fueled by massive
sell offs and rising uncertainty as
multinational companies downgrade their
financial forecasts production at
factories has slowed that's paralyzing
supply chains globally and as more
people stay home stop traveling and
limit their activities to contain the
spread the pain will get worse and
tonight in the US the world's second
largest economy the first hotspot for
the virus is emerging jackson prosecco
reports California is now the focus of
kovat 19 containment in the US where
8400 people are being monitored for
symptoms after a single person tested
positive despite having no obvious
connection to the virus this is a random
individual and a community of 450,000
people
the woman was admitted to hospital not
far from a US Air Force Base where
Americans were quarantined after their
repatriation from Wuhan China a
whistleblower has come forward to say
staff on the base who greeted those
Americans were not properly trained or
protected now that we're seeing it
essentially every continent there's
certainly no attention being paid to
this infection the lack of testing has
hampered any clear sense of how
widespread kovat 19 may be in the u.s.
there are only a limited number of test
kits many have been deemed faulty or
unreliable it's going to disappear one
day it's like a miracle it will
disappear yet the Trump administration
continues to downplay the risk the
reason you're skipping so they're using
so much attention to it today is that
they think this is gonna be what brings
down the president even as public health
officials have warned the situation
remains grave Amazon instructed their
employees to halt all non-essential
travel Google restricted travel to
Europe and Asia after an employee in
Zurich tested positive around the world
jittery markets continued their dive
over fears of a crippling economic
slowdown in New York the Dow and S&P
wrapped up their worst week since the
2008 global financial crisis wiping out
trillions of dollars in wealth while the
US Food and Drug Administration warned
of the first supply chain shortages for
at least one prescription medication the
u.s. plans to drastically improve its
testing capacity within the next week
and that has officials bracing for more
bad news a sudden surge in detected
cases could drastically change the
outlook for the epidemic and further
Rattle already shaky markets Donna
Jackson Prosecco in Washington thanks we
keep reporting the number of confirmed
cases as a measure of how this virus is
spreading but it's not giving the full
picture the only way to confirm a case
is to test no test and you potentially
leave human to human transmission
unchecked disease mapping can predict
what's coming experts at Imperial
College London used Singapore as a
benchmark it was quick to impose
restrictions on travel from China it has
a strict quarantine regime and it's
traced all contacts with infected people
it only has 98 confirmed cases and
Oh deaths so based on what happened
there and looking at travel patterns
from the origin of the outbreak in China
they estimate about two thirds of cases
worldwide remain undetected Italy we
think there are many thousands of cases
probably distributed across the country
now and similarly in and certainly in
Iran probably tens of thousands if not
more many are likely people with mild or
possibly no symptoms but look at China
some there are developing serious
respiratory illnesses and dying not just
the elderly and people with underlying
health conditions the mortality rate is
uncertain but COBIT 19 does appear to be
more deadly than the seasonal flu and no
one has immunity to it
that's why Canada is now moving towards
disease surveillance mode not just
passively waiting for people to show up
at the hospital feeling ill but actively
looking for cases Canada's chief public
health officer has said it's similar to
systems used to monitor influenza and
today Ontario's Health Minister stressed
the risk here is low but preparedness is
ramping up we actually have a command
center that is set up we are prepared
our hospitals are prepared we have the
protective equipment we need to protect
our health officials and we are ready to
to move immediately should the situation
change at any time there are 15
confirmed cases of kovat 19 here in
Canada all the most recent cases are in
people who recently returned from Iran
the numbers are being updated by
countries around the globe by the hour
right now there are more than 84,000
confirmed cases
South Korea's daily increase in cases
has now surpassed that of mainland China
and Iran and Italy appear to be linked
to the newest cases being detected far
beyond their borders crystal commencing
on the spread and the risk Nigeria has
dealt with highly infectious diseases
Ebola malaria cholera and now kovin 19
as an Italian man remains in hospital
outside of the capital he's in high
spirit is doing well
and we expect that we continue to do it
the 44 year old recently arrived from
Milan via Istanbul Nigeria is home to
more than 190 million people a virus
there can spread quickly inside the
country and beyond the Government of
Nigeria to the fair a Ministry of Health
has been strengthening measures to
ensure an outbreak in Nigeria is
controlled and contained quickly
authorities are getting a clearer
picture of the web of infection Italian
cases are connected not only to Nigeria
but Mexico Spain Brazil among others
Canadian cases can be traced to Iran and
then their South Korea Cindy Hsu Garriga
a religious sect there has asked the
public to stop persecuting followers
more than half of South Korean cases
emerged after church members traveled to
Wuhan the World Health Organization is
vigilant but still restrained in its
language if we say there's a pandemic of
coronavirus we're essentially accepting
that every human on the planet will be
exposed to that virus the data does not
support that meanwhile as cases mount
and the concern grows kovat 19 has
claimed the life of the first Briton a
man who had been quarantined on the
Diamond Princess cruise ship crystal
commencing Global News London now to the
disruption rail blockades are having in
this country a second day of talks is
underway in BC between government
leaders and some hereditary Chiefs at
issue is a dispute over a natural gas
pipeline running through with so itand
territory a resolution there could lead
to the blockades elsewhere coming down
Sarah MacDonald is in Smithers BC
tonight Sarah how the talks going Donna
we are told progress is being made
behind these closed doors we're a select
group of indigenous leaders lawyers and
government officials entered into a
second day of talks this morning ready
for constructive and at times difficult
dialogue a second day of high-stakes
talks between government
and indigenous leaders taking place at a
more secure location Friday as all sides
return to the table on the heels of an
emotional and momentous meeting on
Thursday the entire nation needs to be
represented not just a small fraction I
wanted to find out what's going on
because a lot of stuffs been happening
with the protests and we're not involved
involving matriarchs and Chiefs both for
and against a contentious natural gas
pipeline project I just think people are
aware climate change is happening and
that's what I think it's all about
driving a wedge not only through what so
at a nation but all of candidates you
think we're not starting from scratch
and I think that the the that there's a
lot of work that's been done we're
willing to roll up our sleeves and get
to the complex and difficult issues the
meetings are said to be productive but
not easy the parties are very much
engaged as are their teams the the
amount of work being done right now is
substantial substantive and important
and especially so for the with so it in
people feeling the impact of an internal
complex dispute dividing this powerful
nation where they're putting that
pipeline is that's where our fish spawn
and I don't know how our community is
gonna take it when there's no more fish
families and friendships fractured with
livelihoods on the line I understand
about wanting that saves the environment
but also understand that people need to
feed their families as a hiatus on work
and police patrols on indigenous land
stretches into a second day along with
difficult dialogue in an ongoing and
arduous process and no time frame has
been given at this point for how long
this process could last government
officials telling us they are prepared
to stay as long as it takes which could
mean throughout the weekends Donna okay
Sarah McDonald in Smithers VC thank you
this conflict over a natural gas
pipeline and the protests that have
sprung up supporting their hereditary
Chiefs have put three promises made by
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau on a
collision course meeting climate targets
growing the economy by exporting natural
resources and achieving reconciliation
with indigenous people our chief
political correspondent David ake and
joins me David is this a challenge not
just for Trudeau but for the Premier's -
Oh most definitely Donna we have seen
multiple polls over the last few days it
showed very few Canadians approve of the
way some of the key non indigenous
political players involved in this or
handling things just one in five or
twenty one percent of those surveyed
earlier this week by the Angus Reed
Institute said Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau was doing a good job handling
this 21 percent it's about as bad for
some premiers just 18 percent approve of
the way bee sees John Horgan was
handling the crisis just 15 percent said
Ontario's Doug Ford was doing a good job
handling the blockade crisis in his
province the big problem here
particularly for Trudeau and Horgan is
raised expectations that we can have it
all we can have the resource development
we can have effective climate action all
well moving forward on reconciliation
and voters have looked at the last few
weeks and have concluded those
expectations Donna are not even close to
reality they are very high expectations
there are people David who believe that
reconciliation is now dead others are
still hopeful how much have the last few
weeks affected reconciliation well I
don't think it's dead but I think it is
definitely going to be much more
difficult to achieve I mean even within
indigenous communities themselves we
have seen fractures / reconciliation we
have some indigenous leaders who've been
saying these blockades are an
overreaction that will set back the task
of reconciliation of course it's a task
that succeeds only if there is goodwill
on all sides and sadly we are also
seeing a sharp increase in racist anger
aimed at indigenous Canadians both in
confrontations in person at the
barricades and just all over social
media
some news organizations have even had to
shut down comment boards on stories
about the wet so it nor Tyendinaga
because of the volume of racist reaction
the bottom line a whopping 80 percent of
Canadians now say these blockades are
damaging the relationship between
indigenous peoples and other Canadian
it's reconciliation is gonna be tough
Donna it's so much work to do David akin
and Ottawa Thanks
a Global News exclusive investigation
coming up Canadian terrorism offenders
released from prison unreformed and
still radicalized
now to a global news investigation over
the past few years about 130 Canadians
have left the country to join terrorist
groups such as the so-called Islamic
state or al-qaeda some have died others
have been convicted for their crimes and
served time in prison the parole board
reports obtained by Global News suggest
that when some Canadian terrorism
offenders are released they're still
radicalized and as Jeff sample reports
they still pose a threat the rise of the
so-called Islamic state a few years ago
saw a number of Canadians join their
fight Carlos lar Monde from Ottawa was
convicted in 2016 of attempting to join
Isis in Syria sentenced to seven years
and transferred to Canada's highest
security prison last year his parole
board said lahrman had not shown
significant indications of change
attempting to radicalize other offenders
and posed a high risk to public safety
but despite those concerns last December
lahrman was released from prison we have
somebody who has shown no signs of
having abandon the ideology that God
have convicted in the first place and
he's not alone Larr monde is one of five
terrorism convicts freed from Canadian
prisons last year four of whom according
to parole boards still posed a threat we
haven't been really good at developing
any kind of real d radicalization
programs inside the prison system but
it's unclear whether their prison time
would have been long enough for D
radicalization most terrorism sentences
in Canada recently have been seven years
or less their pre-trial custody counts
for time and a half and they're entitled
to statutory release after 2/3 meaning
that most are getting out much sooner it
tells us that the Corps says some 140
does not take terrorism as a serious
offense this Canadian just served 14
years in a US prison for sending money
to an extremist group since his
deportation to Canada a couple of years
ago he's received no contact from police
nobody nobody even contacted my attorney
legal experts note that Canadian
terrorists are typically released under
strict conditions lahrman for example
must live at a halfway house and allow
police to check his phone you're still
being sentenced in that the system is
still why
but it gives you an opportunity to sort
of reintegrate but in rare cases that
reintegration backfires two recent
terror attacks in London England were
committed by convicts who just got out
of prison
the British government responded by
banning early release for terrorism
offenders adding new urgency to the
debate here in Canada with three more
terrorism convicts up for parole this
year Geoff sample Global News Toronto
still ahead a bully boy with a big heart
turns down Disneyland and helps others
instead
grandi Florida support an update tonight
on Quaid unveils he's the nine-year-old
indigenous boy from Australia whose
mother posted this heartbreaking video
of him he said he wanted to kill himself
his mom says kids were constantly
bullying him because of his dwarfism the
video went viral and support poured in a
GoFundMe campaign raised more than four
hundred thousand dollars the plan was to
send him and his mom to Disneyland but
they've turned down the trip they say
they're extremely touched by the gesture
and the outpouring of support but
they've decided to donate the money
instead so we've been talking about it
looking forward to it but my sister said
you know what let's now get back to the
real issue Whedon's family says they'll
donate the money raised to two charities
one that helps people with dwarfism and
the other that works with indigenous
youth from bags to riches next to Quebec
man hits the jackpot after shopping
where he works
you probably thought what would you do
if you won big early retirement maybe or
a never-ending vacation well a grocery
store bagger from Quebec is Canada's
newest millionaire multi
multi-millionaire actually he's 22 and
he bought the winning ticket on Tuesday
night 20 minutes before the deadline and
his Mike Armstrong reports he's going
home with 70 million dollars there's a
car parked outside this grocery store
and for now the owners not coming to get
it one of the backers drove it to work
Wednesday morning for what ended up
being his last shift
the massive check gregory Metsu was
handed Friday morning doesn't quite do
justice to the size of the jackpot he
won he and seven members of his family
are splitting 70 million dollars the 22
year olds days bagging groceries for
12:55 an hour are over financially I'm
good for life and it was a huge stress
for me
Tuesday night Mets you was running an
errand for his mom he'd gone to another
grocery store from the same chain to
pick up milk and a lottery ticket for
the family
the next morning back at his store he
asked a cashier who wasn't busy to check
his ticket and she checked it and I
couldn't believe my eyes and I went to
sit down because I couldn't talk or
thing but juices once he gathered
himself a bit and people stop touching
him hoping his luck would rub off he
called his mom to say they'd won
she understandably figured he was
messing with her well I told him Gregory
are you freaking serious I said your
father and I don't have a budget to miss
work but you actually passed the phone
to a co-worker to confirm the win and
then still had to text his mother a
picture of the winning ticket that's
what she started to believe I was
shaking I was crying no the family
doesn't have any concrete plans yet
likely a big family trip they're very
close but one purchase likely to be made
soon a new car to replace the old one it
was falling apart that's not really a
major concern
anymore my carbs are global news
Montreal that Zamboni driver turned
emergency backup goalie also had a bit
of luck on his side in his NHL debut and
now he's scored a spot in the Hockey
Hall of Fame
that's the hockey stick David Ayres used
to help the Carolina Hurricanes beat the
Toronto Maple Leafs last weekend it is
now on display Ayres called today's
experience surreal he'll remember you as
pressed into action as the backup to the
backup after two injuries he's the first
emergency goalie to win an NHL game and
at age 42
he's also the oldest goalie to win in
his NHL debut we love him and that is
global national for this Friday I'm
Donna freezin tonight's York Canada is
this Golden Goal ten years ago
Sidney Crosby scored against the u.s.
and overtime at the Vancouver Olympics
winning Canada's first gold and men's
hockey on home soil who can forget it
Crosby's goals so iconic it has its own
children's book thanks for watching have
a great weekend and I'll see you back
here on Monday bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you